we are just beginning to glimpse the
bare outlines of an emerging new
economic system the collaborative
Commons this is the first new economic
paradigm to emerge on the world scene
since the advent of capitalism and
socialism in the early 19th century so
it's a remarkable historical event it
has long-term implications for society
but what's really interesting is the
trigger that's giving birth to this new
economic system the trigger is something
called zero marginal cost now
marginal costs are the cost of producing
an additional unit of a good and service
after your fixed costs are covered
business people are all aware of
marginal costs most of the public isn't
but this idea of zero marginal cost is
going to dramatically intimately affect
every single person in the world in the
coming years in every aspect of their
life there's a paradox deeply embedded
in the very heart of the capitalist
market system previously really
undisclosed this paradox has been
responsible for the tremendous success
of capitalism over the last two
centuries but here's the irony the very
success of this paradox is now leading
to an end game and a new paradigm
emerging out of capitalism this
collaborative Commons let me explain in
a traditional market sellers are always
constantly probing for new technologies
that can increase their productivity
reduce their marginal costs so they can
put out cheaper products and win over
consumers and market share beat out
their competitors and bring some profit
back to investors so business people are
always looking for ways to increase
productivity and reduce their marginal
cost they simply never expected in their
wildest dreams that there would be a
technology revolution so powerful in his
productivity that it might reduce those
marginal costs to near zero making goods
and services essentially free priceless
and beyond the market exchange economy
that's now beginning to happen in the
real world the first Inklings of this
zero marginal cost phenomena was with
the exception of the World Wide Web from
1990 until 2014 we saw this zero
marginal cost phenomenon invade the
newspaper industry the magazine industry
and book publishing with the coming of
the world wide web and the internet all
of a sudden millions of people then
hundreds of millions of people and now
40% of the human race with very cheap
cell phones and computers
they're sending audio video and text
each other at near zero marginal cost so
what's happened is millions of consumers
became prosumers with the advent of the
internet and so they're producing and
sharing their own videos their own news
blogs their own entertainment their own
knowledge with each other in these
lateral networks at near zero marginal
costs and essentially for free
bypassing the capitalist market in many
instances altogether this zero marginal
cost phenomena as it invaded the
information industries wreaked havoc on
big big industries newspapers went out
of business they couldn't compete with
near zero marginal cost magazines went
out of business and my own industry
publishing has been just wrecked by free
ebooks and free knowledge and
information but you know the strange
thing about it is at first a lot of
industry watchers said this is a good
thing because if we give out more and
more information goods free and people
are producing and sharing it free these
freemium 's will stimulate people's
appetite to want premiums and then
upgrade this free goods and information
by getting more customized information
I'll give you an example musicians give
away their music free when they started
to see this happen hoping that they
would get a big loyal fan fan repertoire
and then their fans would be enticed to
go to their concerts and pay premium in
order to you know be there in person and
then of course we saw this with
newspapers in New York
we'll give you ten free articles a month
freemium is hoping that you'll then
upgrade to premiums and buy their
subscription service it didn't happen on
any large scale this was very naive by
industry watchers sure some people have
moved from free means to premiums but
when more and more information goods are
out there nearly free shared with each
other music film arts information and
knowledge attention span is not there to
then want to go to the premiums when you
have so much available already in the
freemium 's so economists have come back
recently they said all right we
understand that information goods are
moving toward near zero marginal cost
devastating the newspaper industry
magazines book publishing et cetera but
there's a firewall here that this near
zero marginal cost phenomena on the
Internet
it won't pass the firewall into the
physical world of physical goods and
services the brick and mortar world the
world of energy and physical products
that's no longer the case there's a new
technology revolution coming online
that's making it possible for millions
and soon hundreds of millions and
eventually billions of people to not
only produce and share their own
information goods but now energy and
physical goods and it's called the
Internet of Things this is the expansion
of the Internet and it's all happening
in the last 12 months this is a pretty
new phenomenon what's what's going on
here is the traditional internet that
we're also familiar with is now
converging with a very fledgling energy
internet and a nascent logistics and
transport internet and as these three
Internet's come together they're
creating a single operating platform a
nervous system a sort of intelligent
brain and they're taking this brain and
they're attaching sensors now across the
entire value chain of the economy to
feed into this three Internet's energy
communication and logistics so right now
we have 13 billion sensors out there
connecting appliances and things with
human beings
we have sensors connecting resource
flows in nature we have sensors at
warehouse and distribution centers we
have sensors on smart roads monitoring
traffic we have sensors on the factory
floor constantly keeping up-to-date
information on the flow of production in
the factories we have sensors in the
front and back office in sensors and
retail stores we have sensors all across
the system feeding big data Beth what's
interesting is 13 billion sensors now
IBM says in 2020 we'll have 30 billion
sensors connecting everything with
everything and by 2030 the most recent
forecasts will have a hundred trillion
sensors connecting all of us in one vast
lateral neural network made up of three
operating engines a communication
internet converging with an energy and a
logistics internet and let me say one
more thing about these three engines
when you look back at every society
their economic platforms always contain
three elements a form of communication a
form of energy to power society in the
form of mobility to move economic
activity for example in the 19th century
first Industrial Revolution their
communication was steam power printing
and later the Telegraph to move economic
activity the form of energy was coal and
steam power the form of mobility was the
locomotive and the railroads and that
platform allowed us to build out a first
Industrial Revolution in the 20th
century we had these three as well these
components communication energy and
mobility the communication was
centralized electricity and especially
the telephone later radio and television
the form of energy was oil and the
mobility was the internal combustion
engine and that platform then allowed us
to have a great advance of economic
opportunity in the 20th century a Second
Industrial Revolution this expansive
internet this Internet of Things brings
us to a third Industrial Revolution and
the form of communications the Internet
the form of
power is renewable energy distributed
renewable energy in the form of mobility
is driverless automated vehicles
logistics and automated drones so what
we're seeing is just the first beat the
first Inklings of this new platform
these three Internet's and one and what
this allows us to do is any consumer can
become a prosumer just like we did with
information goods on the old internet
access this new Internet of Things and
have available to us a complete stream
of data from every part of the economy
that means you and I small cooperatives
small businesses large companies if it
keeps its network neutrality we all have
equal access like we did with the
internet so we can go up on this
Internet of Things now and we can take
that big data flowing through the system
from the devices all the way to these
three Internet's and any of us with our
own apps and our own mobile technology
will be able to use the big data and
combine it with analytics to create our
own algorithms just like the big guys at
Google and it won't be rocket science
because they'll be those apps will be
programmed for us so we can create our
own apps with our mobile technology
using that big data to dramatically
increase our productivity reduce our
marginal cost in the production of
physical things like energy and 3d
printed products that's already begun
you